for you in your writing process is that
underpinnings the philosophical
underpinnings of the film the things
that give us lots to talk about
this long after you've first seen the
film are they there when you're first
writing do they come in more through the
production process they came in no they
came in absolute came in in writing
until it took a while to write it
because the the original idea arm was a
song that guy named Charlie Adamson was
a friend of mine who killed the real
Neil McCauley in a shootout in Chicago
in 1963 and it was his appreciation of
his enthusiasm for Neil McCauley and his
admiration form and Charlie was very
much a hunter as detective and they the
scene in the coffee shop it actually
happens he they met each other they
almost got a shootout in the parking lot
and try sell bang cup of coffee and was
in the bailed and dulling in Chicago and
the reason that they came together and
but the the both those components of
their personalities that were the same
the other components were very different
I made it so that it would both true it
one in the same time that they were that
they had the kind of intimacy that only
strangers could have and at the same
time Charlie wouldn't hesitate to blow
me a lot of the socks which eventually
did camp I'd so it was one of those
things where the contrapuntal nature of
it really fascinated me that both their
true it was in the contradiction and so
that's the real kind of germ of the film
and then I for me it never was a genre
exercise in genre it was always there's
these people they're dimensional my own
experience was with and with context
with with professional thieves they're
people they have families they have
mother's father's sister's brothers and
the so it was the appeal of really
digging into the dimensional life of all
the characters
and and their outcomes there was it
fascinated me yeah I mean it's rare to
see a film that is so long and epic but
every character is efficiently drawn
every character has this life of screen